Oh welcome to PlayStation grenade a new
free-to-play game has arrived today on
the ps4 and Xbox one world of warships
legends focused completely around naval
combat between the nautical juggernauts
of history I was eager to get my hands
on legend and luckily the creators
wargaming were ok with that and even
gave me early access so I could put
together an overview and a quick
beginner's guide and they were even kind
enough to sponsor the video to my first
ever sponsored video so thank you very
much wargaming the first thing you
should know about world of warships
legends is that it's an MMO of source
it's ultimately about pitting balanced
teams against each other on the seven
seas so quickly note you'll need to be
online to play this but you won't need
PlayStation Plus each battle we take
part in rewards us with experience and
in-game currency which then feeds into
the gameplay loop play earn XP upgrade
your vessel play some more of course
there's far more to it than that but
that's the core structure the thing
which makes us come back for more let's
jump into an early game something that
impressed me right away about world of
warships legends is that we aren't
instantly sent in to be annihilated
without understanding the basics even
though the game is online only at any
point we can play against AI opponents
to get to grips with mechanics or
practice tactics I've set up ships
differently as most of us on console are
new to this type of game the heads-up
display may be a little confusing but
stick with it all the information you
need is right there for example those
orange circles which move around are
incredibly vital these relate to the
turrets or batteries on your ship let's
lay it down world of warships Legends is
ultimately a simulation each one of
those battlements rotates round in real
time to where you are aiming the
millisecond one of those orange circles
reaches the center point we have another
shot at our fingertips depending on the
positioning of our ship we may have two
battlements available we may have six so
even as a beginner level there are
tactics at work constantly do we attack
head-on and minimize how much of our
ship the opponent can see or do we go
for each side off guns blazing
maximizing the number of battlements
firing at the same time but also leaving
our entire
all open two shots tough choice and
that's where play style comes into it
because for every play style there is
the perfect ship at the launch of world
of warships legends there are three main
types of ship available or classes if
you prefer these are cruisers
battleships and destroyers destroyers
are extremely weak to enemy fire they
make up for this though by being the
fastest movers on the water and also
have a smokescreen to conceal their
location battleships are exactly what
the name suggests they are here to stand
and fight with high levels of armor
allowing them to trade shots at any
distance the additional weaponry and
armor are traded for speed movement and
the huge target they offered the
opposition cruisers are essentially a
middle ground between destroyers and
battleships quick enough to evade some
incoming shots and strong enough to
continuously damage the targets the
cruiser is the best starting class of
all as you discover and decide upon your
favorite play style the sheer number of
ships to unlock is absolutely staggering
and this is where the minutiae of the
game can take hold the stats for each
ship are different for example the first
u.s. ship the Albany has quite modest
stats when compared to a tier 7
Baltimore but in terms of the smaller
target to hit and general concealment
the albany has the edge as you progress
you'll make your own decisions on what
ship is right for you
maybe the Japanese fleet has the perfect
vessel to book rest Awards or maybe the
British I'm currently trying to unlock
the King George the fifth it's the one I
remember the most from history class but
before I become sidetracked by world war
ii history a quick note about a great
mechanic which is unbelievably simple
but also welcoming game at some point
you are gonna be the first ship sank in
battle never fun to be the first man
down but check out this feature we can
leave the match as we're literally
cannon fodder at this point and go back
to our port this will leave your current
vessel in game but allow you to grab
another one of your ships and
immediately get back into the action you
are not forced to sit and wait for the
conflict to end I absolutely love this
and yet mainly because I go on
ridiculous missions to take out the
opposition strong
ship and usually go down in a blaze of
glory you'll still receive all your
rewards if you decide to leave once
you're sunk
and once that match is over your ship
will return to your port I was sat in my
port trying to decide on my next
battleship when suddenly I leveled up
but I love that feature GG developers
[Music]
there are three core weapons and bullet
types to utilize in world of warships
legends once again they impact play
style the first are high explosives and
look the most impressive and cinematic
in battle these are predominantly for
external destruction and can prevent the
enemy from firing their armaments
potentially causing fires which damage
the ship over time we do have a
consumable to put out these fires but it
on a cooldown making fire damage a
constant threat armor-piercing shells on
the other hand are designed to get
inside the enemy ships to get a real
advantage from this you'll need to learn
the anatomy of a ship and perfect your
targeting skills and the trifecta of
attack are these the torpedoes
self-propelled underwater missiles which
the first time you see flying towards
you will genuinely terrify you by
understanding the direction of our foe
we can fire torpedoes and turn a battle
in our favor this linked back to
manoeuvrability where the Destroyers
able to react and avoid torpedoes but
the battleships are more than likely
forced to stand firm and hope to survive
hopefully you can see now how world of
warships legend lairs mechanics and
tactical play on top of one another
here's one more layer to that commanders
commanders are unlocked as we play the
game and can be assigned to each ship in
our Armada commanders come with traits
and skills and ultimately give perks to
tune our warships I've unlocked five
this far let's look at Togo Heihachiro
mi love that name his base stats allows
my consumables to read those slightly
quicker but his real skills are unlocked
by playing more check out this perk
barely out of peril plus 20% ramming
damage dealt and in return
10% is decreased this
perfect for my kamikaze rushes when I'm
being completely outplayed enemy
cruisers suck to a great start some
commanders allow your battlements to
pivot slightly quicker some improve
target acquisition there's a boatload to
choose from did you notice the pun thank
you if you did don't worry if you didn't
follow MIT in terms of game modes
there's multiple and judging by
wargaming's previous titles like World
of Tanks and World of Warplanes more
will be added over time I've played
intense one-on-one battles which is all
about being the first to shoot two on
two which has the first layer of
cooperation and huge a ton eight battles
which I got to admit are my favorite
type on top of that there are other game
modes like domination about holding
capture points and this once again feeds
into the ships you choose will you use a
destroyer to tactically maneuver to
capture points and spot enemies or will
you take the biggest ship you have grab
the opposition's attention whilst your
teammates capture the other points and
don't worry if you think you'll be
overmatched the sides are always
balanced to prevent eight battleships
taking on eight destroyers world of
warships Legends has been built
completely for console gameplay this
isn't a copy-paste part of the PC game
everything has been revamped and in many
cases made specifically for the console
version so if you're like me and you
played the PC version a few years ago
but didn't quite make a connection with
the game now could be the time to try
again and finally as you know world of
warships Legends is a free-to-play title
but over April founders packs are
available to purchase for real-life
money should you want the extras on
offer the premium deluxe and Ultimate
editions offer access to ships some of
which can only be purchased with
doubloons which are legends versions of
fortnight's be bucksaw warframes
platinum these ships can't be earned
in-game and allow us to stand out from
the crowd and impress our comrades our
founders packs include this sexy
founders camouflage 2 as well as
doubloons and credits to spend as you
see fit The Ultimate Edition which is
also the one I opted for has even more
with two tier 4 ships instantly
available whether you choose the
free-to-play route or you want that
founders camo and extras world of
warships Legends is available right now
in the online store completely free to
play if you choose to download it I'd
love to know
our thoughts i've already began to build
a tips and tricks list i just need to
improve a little more and stop ramming
ships
thanks to wargaming for giving me early
access and sponsoring this video I'm
Adam from Playstation grenades
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]